well let's let's talk about the
political ramifications because we got
this philly d.a race
yes it is i've heard about it but you
were saying something crazy so it's
larry
kr krasner is his name he is the
district attorney he was a former def uh
defense attorney and a public defense
attorney and he was a source backhanded
he was soft on crime he
did not um he didn't charge a series of
crimes around the blm
riots including like you know breaking
into windows destroying public
properties during private property
didn't prosecute anything and now he's
being uh primary by the name of carlos
vega who is a prosecutor
as a career prosecutor is puerto rican
descent and he is being challenged
in the district and if this happens it
will be the first soros-backed candidate
to lose after being elected but there's
been a huge surge of murder in
philadelphia like it is
oh yeah i mean we don't we didn't only
get 90s like television shows last year
we got 90s of crime rates in the last
year and this is definitely one of them
and
look at philadelphia i mean these people
they have to live with it and they have
to deal with it so i mean
this is this is it's a democratic
primary by the way so there's no
republicans right it's just democrats
this is what's been happening across the
across the country the cops will arrest
one of these
extremists who are burning things down
or smashing things or punching cops
and then the soros-backed da's or these
leftist da's will just be like there's
no crime here i didn't see anything
and then you get somebody who like
didn't wear a mask at a burger king and
they
prison like banging the gathering they
start beating them like yeah no in
public
no and that's and but they go after the
ones who don't who can't fight
i mean that's the thing and they don't
want to sit there and they don't and
they want to pretend that they're
that they're you know protecting these
people but in the meantime you're having
this lady
and you know who doesn't have a cbs now
to get her insulin from or whatever
drug she was getting and that's the
problem going you know and you're making
life much worse the people you are
promising to protect so i don't know
what i'm trying i was trying to see if
if the election was happening right now
i think that both
votes are coming in about now but i
don't know you know it's probably too
early but
it'll be interesting to see if prasner
goes down because there's dozens of
there's one in la
there's one in uh there's jim fox kim
yeah wasn't she back in chicago yeah
right
and she let jessie smilet go yes yes
talk about talk about
it she's a a woman of the people because
if there's anyone who's really suffering
this life it's jessie smallat
that was the most insane story i
i think i've ever heard and you had wow
he said it's it's what was it like 20
degrees in chicago
no it was like like in the single digits
and there's these two white guys waiting
outside
subway it's subway sandwiches he's by
he's by
the nbc building downtown chicago which
is like a business area and there's like
very few people by the way can i say
he is a actor from the show empire which
no white people watched
like i mean no white people watch the
show empire i would never i did not
hear about i never heard of him until i
saw this i loved the joke where they
were like
yes the two trump supporters who are
familiar with the d-list actor from the
show the show
empire right yeah i'm like there's zero
chance i was like this is
this isn't real right it's amazing to me
how dumb some of these people are that
he couldn't come up with
a better story where he could have just
said a car drove by and a guy yelled
this is moga country and threw a bottle
at him
you know and then he called the cops he
sat in his apartment with the noose
around his neck
for like a half an hour until they shut
up he just sat there with the noose
around his neck
i mean that doesn't raise a flight i
don't know i i
cops were clear i have never had a
newspaper on my neck but i bet you if i
did i wouldn't
sit there with i don't like wearing my
tie like for one more second then i have
to
we wanted to make sure the cops came out
exactly like yeah i'm just gonna sit
there and i don't you know what you know
what i really loved was that like
apparently there was footage
of him with the brothers like walking up
to the area like the day before or
something and like pointing at it
like this is where we're gonna do it
exactly and sitting there and saying oh
you know in eight degree
weather these and it's saying and in
full seriousness he believed that
no everyone would just believe him 100
but they did
no i mean no most people did not believe
him when you get the
was it the big bang theory or whatever
like some show they all like he doesn't
have a career nowadays
well that's because he got he got caught
yeah but at the time
you had all these photos coming out you
had remember when uh um
the the actor we'll just call the the
actor paige to avoid offending anybody
that that the person who played uh um
shadow cat and x-men
okay uh oh uh yeah yeah paige yeah well
i'm trying to avoid being offensive to
literally anybody
former artist formerly known as ellen
page there we go yeah i think that still
might be disrespectful but uh
she was he was formerly known as ellen
page all right technically
well uh paige was on what like was it
whose show was it
uh just like really angrily being like
i'm like yelling about what happened
man imagine being one of these people
right now where they're like you know
the cdc is just very you know
droll you can take off your masks now
and then you're like
yeah my identity
just like a lack of self
yeah so you have these people who go on
tv after the justice mallet thing who
are just like screaming and like
shaking just believing the world is this
insane place
well if you're not if you're not an
interesting person and most people are
not interesting and no offense them but
they're not interesting
and you need to wrap yourself an
identity usually you know
generations ago you either had kids by
by your early 30s you were married or
you had a
career you're building and that was kind
of your whole identity maybe belong to a
civic association of some sort like i
don't know some kind of bowling like
whatever the cases be
that was your identity and it was
wrapped in actually doing something now
if you're like a 35 year old person and
you're either you know in your mom's
basement still because you can't get a
job or you're a single woman and you
have 15 degrees
you know and you can't get a job or
whatever you of course you wrap yourself
in a bigger identity it's how you make
yourself
interesting in some way you know you
know i wonder it kind of feels like
we're all in this pot
and it's being sh you know shaken up
really hard and
like people like us are just sitting in
the corner just like yeah i get it yeah
it's
annoying but there are some people where
every change is making their heads like
they're they're stressed like the blood
pressure on these like
well there is some mentally ill people
on this one oh yeah yeah mental illness
mostly on the left on the left oh yeah
there's this study is done with it and
yeah
um goldberg said that's cool yeah and
there is a lot of mental illness on the
left and
it's probably self-induced at some point
i mean i don't know but there's probably
something
what i mean is i feel like you've got
the you know fouchy for instance
and he's like you you don't gotta wear
masks no you don't it's the
you know you might protect you from a
droplet and then everyone listens and
then a month later he's like you
definitely gotta wear masks
if these people are playing simon says
with this guy so i'm sitting back just
like
uh-huh what's what's the next thing and
it was um who was the guy on
uh on rogan was it uh bill burr
yeah where he was like i just turn on
the tv and it says do i wear a mask or
not i just do it with a tv set
like billboard yeah okay that sounds
like and uh
that's what he said and i'm like these
people are playing simon says to this
guy
if you're if you're in whatever bubble
whatever world we're in
i'm sitting here like this like oh is
that the rule now is that is that what
we're doing i'm just gonna mind my own
business
it's flipped and changed too much i'm
chilling but imagine you are one of
these people
and they tell you wear a mask first to
say don't wear a mask they say wear mask
then they say oh oh no the vaccine will
never get on oh no the vaccine's done oh
now now even if you eat the vaccine you
gotta wear a mask first for no apparent
reason you cannot take the mask off
these people are like being flipped like
pancakes over and over again
and they're probably at some point like
their blood pressure must be through the
roof
because all they know is i trust the
authorities i trust
the elites i trust the establishment but
they keep getting
like i don't know what simon says
without you i don't know how much of it
is like i
hate trump and i want to show how great
i am in hating republicans conservatives
i'm going to still wear my mask and how
much was i
genuinely fear from my health because
there are those people who have genuine
like
paranoia fear and this is all like
coming out and how much was like this is
no this is part of my identity i wear a
man like david hogg who's like i'm going
to wear a mask because i don't want to
be
because i don't want to be a
conservative so i'm going to sit there
and just you know
and it's i'm just saying it's also not
healthy for you to wear a mask all the
time like you can't like can't
get dirty yeah yeah healthy filthy
i'm wondering at what point do these
people just drop to their knees and like
their eyes go out opposite direction
they go
ah because you cannot follow
no rules you know what i mean like so
the woke left will say
women is offensive because not inclusive
so you got to say whimxen
but why mix it is offensive because it
changes women and now it's exclusive
how do you live in a world where there's
no rules if you do not have mental
fortitude
your brain is probably going to explode
at some point yeah
you're going to fall down and just
scream in combat especially people lose
their mind they panic they fall down
they can't
they can't shoot they're just laying
there you have to force them down on the
ground i was talking to forrest about
this a little bit yesterday as army
ranger for a while
like you just you just push them down on
the ground and continue to do your job
without them don't pay them attention
they're screaming they're loud
unfortunately these people have access
to social media are making a big loud
noise
and they run the institutions yeah and
when laws get made
after because of panic that's disturbing
that's really disturbing yeah
yeah and that's but that's when they use
it see here's my frustration with the
right after covet covid was like
the problem with the right is like we do
things like we complain about public
education for 45 years saying it's a
horrible
horrible institution with lots of
fallacies which it is it's true
and then they shut down every school in
the country and our our go-to knee-jerk
reaction is let's open the public
schools again
the thing we've hated for 45 years no
let's go right back to that it's not
like hey
maybe we could like you know give every
parent a certain amount of money if they
want to homeschool or send their kids to
a private school or a religious school
whatever the case is
and we'll massively change our education
this will be the opportunity
this is the crisis we'll use to
fundamentally alter education
the left always does that the right
never does that did you see that and
they're idiots for doing
the tweet from the gop where they were
like you know
thousands of mothers have chosen yeah
with their kids yes oh my god i was like
what is
wrong with you people i'm like this is
what we always
talked about like oh my god they have a
parent at home how
wonderful they've they the the overton
window has gone so far left
the republicans are outraged that more
women aren't leaving their kids with
in daycare and going to work yeah and
and you would think that this is the
time to sit there and really restructure
society friendly friendly iberowicz uh
who i'm a really big fan of
she was like oh it's so great that
there's no more tourists in new york
city because i hate tourists but also
the new york city economy just crashed
and uh she's like they're like we're
gonna get back to normal normal wasn't
great we could actually make things
better
but the diff but if you're not a
visionary person and a lot of people on
the left i give them credit are
visionary people they have a dream of
what america is going to look like it's
not the dream i really
you know subscribe to but it's their
dream those on the right they don't have
you know a vision and i say this
politician all the time when i consult
with them i say
tell me what if you were going to run
whatever you're running for mayor
congress president whatever it is if
you're going to run whatever you're
going to run for a decade tell me what
it looks like and i don't want to hear
the words
free market liberty or freedom i don't
hear any buzzwords
i want you to describe to me where i can
close my eyes i can walk through a town
that you want to be mayor of
and i want to see what that town will
look like that is drastically different
than the world i have now
and if you don't have that vision you
can't explain it to me who spends my
whole life in here you can't explain
anybody else to be
fair it's true you know they probably
don't have a vision of what the world
should look like they just have you know
certain you know platitudes
tax cuts for apple yeah yeah but but the
the creativity or like the ideas of the
left in their vision
you know look they they might have a
vision but it's like hovercrafts and
unicorns
flying through the air oh it's it's an
it's a crazy vision applicators
producing free cheeseburgers and
everyone's fit and healthy
yeah if you put lsd in your oatmeal
that's the visions you get but that's
that's not like that's that doesn't mean
that you shouldn't have
an alternative aside from oh we'll just
make enough tax cuts that the world will
be better
there is something in between there is a
vision of education is really important
a lot of people care about it and we've
complained for half a century about it
and we shut down every public school in
the country and we thought of no
alternatives besides open up every
public school in the country back up
that's problematic that shows you don't
have that means a serious lack of vision
and leadership i was i was excited when
the schools got all got shot
schools are trash and i was like
homeschool your kids these pods things
that sounds great yeah where they
like you get one parent to like watch
the 40 kids or whatever and then they
trade off yes
that's illegal in some states in some
communities and that should be the
number one thing people should campaign
on making sure that if you have a
a former math teacher on your block and
sheik is not allowed to sit there and
bring
all the kids from the block to sit there
and learn math that's horrible and
that's what i'm thinking
the governor should have signed
executive orders immediately and done
that but they didn't because
you know people between the years
they're not they don't have a lot of
things going on there so i guess
that's one of the biggest problems we
have in the culture war is you've got
people who are opposed to something and
people who want something psychotic
yeah and you don't have the alternative
to sit there and say what is
what does you know what would benefit
america that you could provide and use
the government
use the power of government in some
positive sense they do this in other
countries on the right
and i get that america has some
attachment to the idea of
you know liberty and but i think that
most people do want some kind of
security they do want some kind of
vision from their leaders
and you know that's why we slowly lose
every institution
they erode everything across the board
and and if you don't i mean the one
thing that we've kind of won on as guns
as you mentioned i mean
the right has one on guns but that's
because you had a group of people who
were singularly focused who had a vision
the vision was you can buy a gun without
a license
and when in 1986 there was only one
state in the country that had that law
which was vermont of all places
and now it's like over 18 states that
have that law
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you